hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book three of his confessions saint
augustine brings up something that was a
puzzle and a problem
for him at the time that he was first
thinking about it and encountering it
and it's something that
constitutes an obstacle or a hindrance
or an opera going in and not being able
to find your way out
for many people
down to the present and augustine
himself has a solution to this which he
has worked out in this and in other
works it's sort of his standard approach
to distinguish between
a divinely given law that can be the
same everywhere
and then
local human customs which can be
suspended or abrogated or even
contradicted by god's commands and how
how does this work this does in fact
constitute a
significant problem for a lot of people
and he gives some examples those who
complain when they hear that a certain
thing was listed that is okay for the
righteous in another age whereas it's
not permitted to them in our time
god commands one thing for some people
and something for others and they're
saying how does this make sense isn't
there a contradiction here you know you
could think about the famous example of
abraham god says go take your son
sacrifice him on this mountain and you
know we can say oh well i'll go
sacrifice my kid and then you know the
answer is no no no no that's that's for
abraham
not for you of course in that case
god actually sends an angel who
stops the operation
and augustine identifies
at the very end of chapter
seven in book three
why it was that he
fell into some problems with this he
says
i did not perceive how justice
contains in a far more excellent and
sublime manner at one in the same time
all that it commands and still is in no
part in variance with itself and how at
various times and not all at once it
distributes and commands what is proper
so what he's saying is that justice
itself
can include a lot of different things
and they're not really in contradiction
with each other
it appears so if we have the wrong point
of view if we have a mistaken point of
view that if we don't have the correct
point of view and he says that what i
was not understanding
is true interior
justice right
that is
another way of talking about the justice
that that god is providing
which judges he says not according to
custom
consuetuding
right
and there's different latin words for
custom this can also be translated as a
kind of
habitual custom something that we we get
used to you know for example here in
america you might say that a little bit
facetiously because we actually do have
laws about this
driving the speed limit is not what we
actually do on most roads in particular
highways
as a matter of fact you're expected to
be going the speed limit or maybe even a
little bit over and if you're just
driving the speed limit and you're
saying the left-hand lane the passing
lane people are gonna be honking at you
and getting mad at you the cops might
actually pull you over for that if
you're driving in their view too slow
um that's an example of of a custom
right in other places maybe you do drive
the speed limit maybe the speed limits
are strictly enforced right we we vary
too as well if you're driving
over the speed limit in a school zone
okay then it's taken a bit more
seriously right so not according to
customs these constituted suatudines
but rather according to what
law
the most righteous law of almighty god
and he says
by this law
the customs of various regions and times
were adapted
to times and places
but the law itself the divine law
is everywhere and always the same it's
never one thing in one place and
different in
another let me give some examples here
according to that law abraham and isaac
and jacob and moses and david so four
are actually five very important
biblical figures all of whom exercised
authority all of whom did things
they were all just people but by
ignorant people who judged by man's day
and measured the ways of all mankind by
their own
particular customs they were judged to
be unrighteous and he's got a good sort
of metaphor here
it's as if a person who knew nothing of
armor and could not tell what a piece is
made for what member would try to cover
his head with a grieve
or put a helmet on his leg so the greave
is the piece of armor that goes on your
leg and you know obviously you can't get
your head in it it reminds me of my
oldest daughter when she was very little
and learning to dress
herself she got i heard a yell from the
other room
and i came in to see her struggling to
put a pair of pants
on as if it was a shirt and she had both
arms in leg holes and was trying to
figure out where the the head hole was
and obviously there wasn't one on the
pants so you know this is a a good
metaphor right the law is always the
same customs can be adapted to
times and places and so these situations
or cultures or times and places those
are variable but justice itself
in what it is
are not
it is not rather right justice itself is
still
justice and commanding
the same thing
and so
how can we make sense of this augustine
gives us in chapter 8 a bit more
insight he says listen there's some
things that are always
going to be
right and you should be doing them and
he gives as an example of this the two
commandments that christ himself gives
when he's asked what are the greatest
commandments
um
at that time there were a lot of
different mitzvot or commandments and
and christ picks out um two in
particular you shall love god
you know entirely you could say here
it's it's phrased
as loving god with your whole heart and
whole soul and whole mind okay that's a
thing that will always be right
always good always you should be doing
that
and loving your neighbor
as yourself
now he has a corollary to this
therefore
vicious deeds that are contrary to
nature are everywhere and always
detested and
punished now the very case that he's
going to bring up will show us that
not always not every culture gets it
right in every single case he talks
about sodom and there you know this is
from the story in genesis he talks about
the men of sodom if you you know if
you're curious about that story read it
you know um rather than
just
sort of shooting from the hip
there are several interpretations of
what was wrong
with the men of sodom
and one of them has to do with sodomy
you know unnatural sexual actions and
augustine might have that in mind here
but another was the uh opposite of
hospitality preying
upon those who you should be treating as
guests who you should be honoring
instead
you know the men of sodom demand
that
the the guests should be thrown out
among them so that they can do whatever
they want to them maybe both of those
are part of the thing but augustine is
saying listen there's some things that
are just wrong
and
what you know
was it being condemned in sodom at the
time to the saud did the sodomites have
a set of rules that said you're not
supposed to do this probably not right
maybe that was a culture where this rule
or law of god was being disregarded and
that's why the punishment comes right
but there's a lot of things that are
pretty universally acknowledged if you
look across the board and cultures don't
kill people without a good reason they
don't always say don't kill period don't
steal other people's stuff
you know whatever sort of rules there
are about sexuality you know whether you
can have it before you're married or
can't or whether you know fidelity
matters follow those you know there's
all sorts of things that are pretty much
constants augustine would say and that's
because those are the things that are
being you know commanded by divine
justice
and you know part of those are within
our hearts you could say and he says
even if all nations would do these deeds
they would be held in equal guilt under
the divine law
it has not made human beings in such
fashion that they should use one another
in this way
foreign truth society itself which must
obtain between god and us is violated
when the nature of which he is an author
is polluted by a perverse lust
then he goes on and he says the the bad
things which are contrary to human
customs
also have to be avoided according to the
diversity of customs so if there's a
law against you know spitting on the
sidewalk because people really don't
like it
you shouldn't violate that law even
though that's kind of an arbitrary thing
right you say well that's just that
particular
culture uh you know those of us from
where we spit on the sidewalk because
you know we're expressing phlegm getting
rid of you know things that are bad for
us right uh expressing a certain sort of
rivalry with who can spit the furthest
that's over here and that's okay here
but if we're in somebody else's place as
he says you know as travelers uh or
citizens we shouldn't violate
the custom of the city or nation unless
unless of course
it goes against um you know the things
that we're supposed to do or
here's where the kicker comes in unless
god says don't follow that rule god
makes it clear that in this
case in this situation in this time and
place
there's a different rule so he says when
god commands something contrary to the
customs or laws of a people it must be
done even if it's never been done before
if it has been neglected it must be
restored if it's never been established
it must be established
why
because god is the ultimate ruler
god you know takes care of everything
and so even a
king commanding within the city you know
god takes precedence over him and he is
the king who can
make rules about something that neither
he nor any predecessor had ever
obeyed
and he says if it's not against social
principles for him to be obeyed or
rather be against the principles of the
society for him to be not obeyed for
it's a general law of human society for
men to obey their rulers
how much more must god ruler of all
creation be obeyed without hesitation
right so this is what we call an ah
fortiori argument if you're gonna say
that the legitimate authorities that
you're supposed to listen to are
supposed to be obeyed
what about the like total capital a
authority who created
everything and then there's an
interesting discussion about
what it means to go against god's laws
this is in chapter eight and also in
chapter nine he says that there's a lot
of different and we we've got different
words for this crimes
sins evil deeds vices these are all
basically connected together in the same
spectrum and he says that you know we do
crimes when we have a desire to do
injury either by abuse of language or
violence
these can be for the sake of revenge or
the sake of gaining some external profit
or for this the sake of escaping evil
like when we're afraid somebody else is
going to hurt us and we go overboard or
out of envy right and he says these are
main kinds of wrongness iniquity they
spring forth from lust of power
or lust of the eyes or sensuality
whether from one or of these or two or
all three together these are basic
human motivations for doing the wrong
thing and going against the divine
commands or the divine law or the laws
of one's own country the
customs right
these are the things that motivate us to
do
wrong
and so he says that
you know these don't actually hurt god
himself
it hurts us
when we do the wrong thing
we damage our self
the human being's iniquity lies to
itself whether by corrupting and
perverting their own nature which god
made and set an order or buying a
moderate use of things allowed to us or
with regard to things that are not
allowed to us by a burning lust for use
which is contrary to nature we
screw ourselves up in these cases we
make ourselves worse off and we also
wrong others as well and then god
although we're not going to hurt god
right by doing something that's wrong
and now he says this is quite
interesting this is in chapter nine
we don't always know what's going on
with people
he says along with these base deeds and
crimes and so many other iniquities
there are the sins of those who are
making progress
these sins are reprehended by good
judges in the light of the rule of
perfection so there's like a high
standard
but they're also praised out of a hope
of fruit
as is the blade for the grain the
blade of wheat growing up for for the
the grain that will happen
there are certain things that seem like
vice or crime but are not sins because
they don't offend god or human society
for example and augustine has some great
examples here a person gathering for a
time certain things suitable to their
needs
it's uncertain whether they do this out
of greediness
avarice or
whether certain acts are punished by a
proper authority with a view to
correcting them and it's uncertain
whether this was done out of a desire to
inflict harm so there's a lot of things
that we don't know the outward
appearance of the deed is one thing the
mind of the doer and unknown
circumstances are another
who's the judge in that case i mean we
can judge by appearances god is actually
the judge and the divine law
is the judge
and he he tells us you know one other
thing that i want to close with here
he says that you know very often we're
being driven by a kind of pride desire
for a false freedom
and this avarice of having more and more
so you know greed and pride are key
issues and what what do these involve
there's a formula here that is very
typically augustinian
putting more love
love is in desire for something love is
in valuing something
on our own
personal good and he uses the plural
there we our own personal goods
rather than on god so we have to choose
sometimes
be seemingly between our own personal
goods and god but we actually don't have
to right it's understanding our own
personal goods in relation to god who is
as he's going to say
the good of all that is the
bonum
omnium right the good of the totality so
we have a choice we it's not as if we
can't pursue our own good but we need to
do so in a
reasonable limited way subject to
the divine law which you know includes
some things that we can always bank on
love your neighbors yourself
and some things where you know we may
get a direct revelation do this rather
than what your society can uh commands
you to do or there may be other
permutations as well
you